même si j'en garde un bon soir bonsoir
alors quand on vous demande pourquoi m6
jean gabin parce que c'est vrai que
quand même vous dites je pouvais pas
prendre alain delon parce que c'est un
facho un trou de balle exact ouais exact
tu prends maintenant que jean gabin
pendant laquelle serait jean gabin
puisque dans les acteurs que j'aimais
bien quand j'étais plus jeune il y avait
jean gabin paul maurice ainsi paul
meurisse et à bientôt sur m6 courbine
alors vous êtes un fan faut dire aussi
des tentes ont flingueurs de touche pas
au grisbi de mélodie en sous sol pour
retrouver
c'est bizarre bizarre la technique enfin
c'est pas la wii vous êtes un fan des
tontons flingueurs de touche pas au
grisbi de mélodie en sous-sol cc ou qui
à charles qui est un ancien braqueur
sait dans quel film c'est dans mélodie
en sous sol et l'a dit un sous sol
j'entends mais bien en fait parce que
vous vous êtes un ancien braqueur et
puis votre vrai prénom ses chars ses
chars ouais c'est peut-être pour ça que
vous avez pris m6 jean gabin ou les deux
sources mais ça coulait de source vous
connaissez jack lang oui je veux juste à
l'heure et je veux connaissent en tant
que ex ministre
fils de fritz lang
vous le connaissez vous béatrice michon
kaba koné tous les rappeurs vous l'aimez
bien oui à paris qu'un truc dans sa
chanson qui m'énerve 28 de sa famille
dans sa chanson l'aller dit du mal de
bruit en voulait ben j en veux il sait
pas qu il explique ses raisons de toutes
vérités ne sont pas bonnes à dire bien
longtemps donc à partir du moment après
c'est les sa divergent il ya des pour et
les contre et vu que tu es proche excuse
moi de te tutoyer tu vois donc voila
quoi parce que bon il ya un moment où ça
réduit vachon excuse-moi défendre parce
que je connais qui a évidemment c'est
des gens que j'aime ouais mais
maintenant le diocèse non je reçois pas
jusqu'à moi je trouve ça juste dans dans
la mesure où je me dis que c'est une
génération c'est la première génération
de rappeurs qui a eu stagnara ntm pas
biais de formats people et de bio et
cesse ce sont ceux là qu'ils ont prôné
on était contre tours excusez moi nicky
le système ils sont rentrés les deux
pieds dedans le moulin intérieur clapet
ils font exactement la même chose que
les gus qui l'ont critiquée avant eux tu
m'excuseras tu peux pas critiquer sur la
rai me balancer la gazelle derrière il
ya un truc je te regarde et je te dis ça
va ma gueule terrible chouette ouah
c'est pas ça c'est c'est facile de
prendre un fanion voilà aujourd'hui
c'est la misère ou comme en politique
c'est la sécurité
qui
va supermarché tu vas gagner lâchement
d'oseille tu vas pas peut-être en
profiter aussi ce que je trouve sympa
normal quoi et moi je serais pour à ce
que je fais avec mon l'oseille pour
l'instant j'ai pas de fois je peux pas
les toucher non après quand les mecs ont
du succès on leur dit ouais les mecs
vous rentrer dans le moule maintenant on
sent qu'il est ou bien en place nous
donne a changé il dénoncer des choses
qu'ils ont vécu qu'ils ont dit à un
moment où est dénoncée la sociologue
robert il ya un moment quand tu
critiques giné court 10 ans qui fait de
la soupe et tu fais exactement la même
chose que gynéco tu m'excuseras l oral
c'est une musique comme une autre il ya
de la variété dans la boue ne faisait
pas de variation pour maintenir le vieux
cesseront de la mariette c'est tout
temps coûte entre les refrains olé olé
c'est vraiment tu dis alors votre vrai
nom c'est donc charles ambush d'origine
camerounaise née en 67 père comptable
mère dactylo et vous êtes 5e qui sur une
famille de douze voilà alors quand vous
avez 9 ans vos parents divorcent et
votre père supporte pas et vous dites il
repasse il repasse votre mère et son
nouveau mec dans un parking voilà 37 rue
saint forgeot en 77 oneway un repas
c'est ça veut dire assassiné quand ça
s'ils ne les assassine et comment c'est
d'abord il a touché mon père il a touché
le conjoint bammer ouais et après il
s'est occupé de ma mère ouais moi
j'appelle ça c'est ch ouais c'est si tu
as des bus en temps pas besoin de faire
tout ça en plus si la personne veut
plutôt à ça lui dire au revoir mais bon
voilà salut à part amener votre mère
dans tous les cas savoir pas me ramener
non plus mais voilà ensuite vous dites
il part en calèche c'est à dire en
prison il ya il a pris combien de paires
bon à mon père l a fait en tout cinq
piges et nuit c'est à dire tous les jeux
c'est pas beaucoup bah ouais cinq mois
après il a fait autant que moi pour
braquo ouais voilà pourquoi bon on est
passionnel crime passionnel et en plus
c'est là il a eu du bol plus que il a
échoué il a échappé au couperet ouais il
ya 80 et 81 2 c'est la peine de mort et
est témoin aurait vu ses fonds 70 ans
donc j'ai pas capté on voit la tête
après cinq années pour braconnage ouais
ouais braconnage j'ai fait cela pendant
mon sac
il est où votre père mon père il doit
l'état duplex inquiète par pearl away ça
va ce son problème et vous le voyez plus
gros cherche moi ouais voilà donc vous à
l'époque vous partez à la dass vous
parlez de la dass en expliquant que
finalement les abus sexuels sont très
fréquents c'est fréquent est beaucoup
plus fréquent que les gens croient ve et
le bizutage
le bizutage est fréquent et le problème
c'est pour revenir maintenant
avec les ctf qu'ils essayent de faire je
sors des centres techniques éducatif est
dans un centre technique éducative tu
apprends qu à une chose savoir que
ceux qui ont ce qu'on te promets
n'existe pas moi je veux un coup un
numéro donc tu doit rapporter tu es déjà
adultes avant l'âge mais donc la société
avant tu sais que c'est une variante va
rien amené c'est que du pipeau ouais et
le problème dans ces trucs là c'est
quand vous êtes enfermé pour ceux qui
sont la famille c'est bien pour ce
qu'ils en ont pas faut se démerder donc
abus sexuels de toutes sortes et quand
vous avez une petite bulle ce qui passe
ça y va aussi vous dites temps meilleurs
amis c'est à fourchette très ton
meilleur ami c'est à fourchette parce
que quand ils rentrent à 13 ans quand tu
aurais quand tu rentres à 13 ans en
maison de correction puisque c'est comme
ça c'était fou centre technique éducatif
vaut mieux avoir deux trois poteaux
quant à 13 ans car on aura moins de
problèmes avec ce 17 mai raconte quand
vous rentrez vous en avais 12 10 il ya
peut-être d'autres problèmes avec ce 17
mai qui justement n'ont pas de bons
rapports sexuels avec la gente féminine
s'occuperont des plus petits voilà alors
à 17 ans vous vous retrouvez à paris et
là vous découvrez le hip hop mais la
branche dure du hip hop à la dépouille
la dépouille était un moyen de 2
becqueter survivre voilà braqueurs quoi
ouais ces braqueurs de petite envergure
les petits faubourg way rapide une paire
de chaussures une rapide à son brave et
rapide toute chose c'est pas des banques
qua non les banques c'est venu plus tard
il a failli à l'enfer 2 basé e
l'acheminement social justement vous
faites les petites institutions jusqu'à
aller jusqu en calèche en calèche vous
après l'école du vice et de orbe assez
soit ratp juniors hommes casse-dalle non
mais franchement préféré l'autre ouais
vous êtes dans le gangsta rap à ce
moment là non non j'ai j'écoutais du
games europe mais vous vous circulez
avec les requins vicieux quand même
c'est pas des mecs très à elle retient
vicieux sont mes amis dont un cousin
mais les requins vicieux avant tout
c'est une famille on était justement ce
qu'on s'est servi de substitut parce
qu'on avait pas chez nous soient sains
père soit il mais roux et forcément les
plus faibles à ce fonds occuper les plus
gros est dedans il faut manger donc
chacun son activité dans tout travail
mérite salaire et voilà voilà alors à un
moment ça commence à sentir le roussi
pour vous un charge et vous partez en
allemagne et là vous tombez pour
braquage et fait 50 dollars bien moins
vite yao mobile tegel 1 c'était
une bonne expérience car dans les
mauvaises il faut apprendre et dans les
bonnes il faut apprendre aussi là
j'étais dans une mauvaise mais elle m'a
servi de
beaucoup servi chaud que db limite je
maintenant je commence à jacter de troie
qui l'engagent en plus
on va réellement vient quand même un
problème qu'est ce que ça vous a appris
à part à part l'allemand à part
l'allemand
quand vous arrivez par exemple dans un
beau pays comme la france bien où
théoriquement c'est l'eldorado et en
voisin où on vous accueille avec un
grand sourire 1 alors que de l'autre
côté est théoriquement c'est des fois
chaud des néo nazis alors que vous
pouvez trouver un travail en ayant
quatre épingles sur le sur le terrain on
vous vend rien tandis qu'en france fait
la même chose en bo3 alors parce que
l'habit fait le moine à vous ressortez
de cette tôle à berlin à 27 ans au total
vous savez comme été enfermés dix sept
ans si on fait le convoi s'est dirigé la
vache c'est cette pige avec la calèche
ne faisait pas attendu le rap pour être
révolté vous en tous les cas un non pas
du tout alors vous disiez tout à l'heure
que joey starr faisait du doc gynéco ce
qu'un peu exagéré mais non vous c'est
gynéco qui vous a demandé de devenir rap
est alors au début je n'avais rien à
[ __ ] vouliez faire un bouquin au
départ ouais au départ je voulais faire
un bouquin ouais puisque je voulais
toucher une autre partie de la populace
est bon gyneco il m'a appelé
et je me suis pris au jeu voilà et ça
vous plaît ouais c'est ses manches alors
vous en étiez avec la justice maintenant
avec la justice bas ça va j'ai juste
cinq ans de mise à l'épreuve et pour
cocaïne ouais pour coquio pourra vous
dire et de la cocaïne ah ouais je survis
1 je survis il faut il faut le savoir
moi quand on me dit l'argent sale c'est
vrai l'argent sale mais l'argent sale à
la rive sur quelle table vous regardez
ce qu'ils font leurs trucs là avec leur
pétrole et leur baratin à gauche à
droite en 10 sec de l'argent propre mais
cela quand il va en calèche s'ils vont
jamais un mois j'ai besoin de manger je
suis dans un bled où je suis né où j'ai
fais pipi de la nation ça fait 8 qui
gémit j'ai pas mes faf vous pouvez dire
j'ai pas mes fans n'avaient pas de tapis
j'ai pas de papiers je suis d ici j'ai
fait l'armée j'ai été exemptés à chaque
fois que j'ai quelques mois comme sera
baratin de france 5 en un donc un moment
je me dis hé les gars voulaient pas que
baic je vais becqueter même si je dois
aller à la rate allergie à l'intérieur
mais j'irai manger parce que la vie
c'est pas attendre la part c'est quoi la
ratez rien c'est la prison c'est pas la
calèche assez la même qu'à tel qui
allège donjon raté hier avec blaise à la
fois que vous avez peur de retourner en
prison
cette fois que j'ai peur de retourner en
prison mais je voudrais pas y aller
ouais vous dites c'est la haine pe du
vice c'est là une peu difficile a aucune
réinsertion du continent à se mettre ton
prochain larcins c'est clair je suis
resté douze mois avec un gus s'appelait
josée-anne entier qu'ils aient des bras
qu à l'ancienne les postes etc et moi je
suis rentré dedans n'est en n'ayant rien
fait au même en ayant offert un petit
vide pendant 12 mois j'ai appris en
théorie comment braquer ouais c'est tout
ouais les mecs et vous adhérez
d'économie course était mon prof mais
c'est pas très bon prof si le mec il est
derrière les barreaux sa main mais c'est
pas grave tu apprends des erreurs des
autres diack j'ai quelque chose à dire
exane aurait des mecs comme lui mais
j'écoute avec avec attention jeu requis
la manière de raconter sa vie qui est
qui qui touche aux qui est très proche
d'audiard ses vrais
rivaux pas seulement écrire des du rap
est vrai qu'il ya des films maintenant
un bain
sarkozy les lois sarkozy vous en pensez
quoi chauffer c'est du réchauffé c'est
du réchauffé du réchauffé qu'est ce qui
va changer il parle d tapant à longueur
de journée tu vas sur le périph qui vont
pourvoir au titre fait sucer intrigue
ses films
ok
sarkozy attend parce que ça ça m'a fait
rigoler c'est une carte de mon client tu
peux revenir quand tu me
charles vous croyais en quoi je crois en
moi ouais l'amour oui mais c'est
malheureux de croire en l'amour et c'est
malheureux d'être amoureux et puis pas
croire en l'amour ouais voilà votre mère
elle vous aime je pense que ouais ouais
votre grand mère aussi ouais votre fille
aussi bien aux filles aussi donc vous
croyez au moins à l'amour de ces trois
femmes ouais ça c'est clair ça s'arrête
là ouais vous prions dieu pas du tout
pourquoi parce que y'a way n'est jamais
venu au parloir j'avais vu
et jamais vu au parloir et je pense que
quel est le père qui laisserait crevé
ses gosses sont jamais bougé le petit
doigt
mais leur servent quand même c'est la
faute des z'arts well medef aussi
sa trouvaille
je ne fais pas la portée des mossi alors
donc voilà donc dont je t'emmerde on l'a
dit tout à l'heure et béatrice dalle
vous tapez sur l'intégralité du rap
français même joey starr qui pourtant me
semblait à l'abri quand même de ce
jardin d'attac alors on va me faire une
interview si on disait du bien
[Musique]
alors chat même si jean gabin si on
disait du bien de joey starr vous diriez
quoi
ça a été un précurseur à moi tu vois si
on disait du bien de kery james vous
diriez quoi bon rappeur de kool shen
récurent sur de lord kossity grande
saucisse à vous arrivez pas je
n'arrivais pas à dire du bien de l'ordre
que c'est justement un ss et pit
baccardi
pit baccardi bon pique assiette aie
pitié
vous aller taguer où les enfants
surprise ils sont formidables ce que le
décor ils leur font mais j'ai
l'impression excuse-moi granby leur foi
envers
changera pas beaucoup changé l'esprit y
est pour quelque chose à lady laistee où
vous
joli petit arrière train et des nouveaux
seins tout neuf
m6 là bas je lui tire mon chapeau c'est
l'un des rares qui est toujours là ouais
mais voilà qu'à des mots comme un ipad
il a pas tourné savez s'il arrivait un
que le même âge la même j'avance du
début jusqu'à la fin que la cena dans la
variante salut je suis là
la rumeur
j'écoute point troussier politicards
c'est pas mal à la rumeur laisse à
chacun sa soupe en
doc gynéco ouais merci mon pote
voilà mais ce qui fait comme les et ce
qu'il fait comme musique de la variété
il le dira mais il
est vraiment un filet d'eau mais à moins
de succès qu'avant à la roue tourne
ouais mais bon je pense qu'il a il a
fait son job voilà et puis si maintenant
il veut tirer sa révérence qui
n'attirent pas ce que beaucoup devraient
faire d'ailleurs un effet avoir les
moyens de tirer sa révérence arionas ça
fait déjà 10 piges qui sont là je pense
qu'ils ont pris ça y est ils ont rêvé
dentier maintenant falloir
des jo si tu sur ton temps tu peux avoir
les mômes sur le dos il ya des jours tu
aimerais bien longs mois c'est un petit
bisou en serait une fille
[Musique]
à
commencer par la star salut c'est la
dernière journée lui qui chantait vous
étonner mais 3 vous êtes looké comme
c'est pas possible
là c'est énorme
vous connaissez tu connais piccoli non
pénale picouly la cjv chanel mais en
face m6 jean gabin bonjour monsieur
blaise le connaître vu
la mousse carresse pas où il est
qu'est ce qui se passe
du bon temps pour qu'il retrouve je vais
venir devant ce spectacle en spectacle
il reprend quand je reprends je n'ai pas
vu le prix je reprends je reprends je
reprends je peux les mains des
abominations si les noirs étaient avant
quand j'étais noir avant quand ce n
est qu est ce que tu fais tu fais des
clips alors là j'ai fait
j'ai deux amours mon pays paris ah ouais
ouais qui aurait dû arriver
théoriquement pour noël et l'on y
arrivera un peu plus tard et je vais
faire le troisième l'a
aussi vu concéder voilà
gnl casse burnes nom
barbare c'est simple tu écoutes moi
j'avance voix aiguë si l'arrivée il
arrivait dans le cinoche et à 36 berges
moi je suis arrivé dans la seule dans la
chanson en trente
et un lien de panau des environs moi
c'est la même
et puis il a fait comme moi hilare
tapissier son blason simple et mon congé
voilà c'est
génial c'est qu'il a un côté que le thon
années 50 sa façon de parler
lui parle comme audiard tu vas y à pas
du tout il est descendu par les ouais
c'est toi c'est tonton flingueur quoi
ouais c'est me novion sursis sur les 35
heures mais si tu appelles chars et le
mec qui s'appelle charles
le jour où j'ai j'ai vu ça y'a quoi 4,5
puis sur une vidéo j'étais dans un vieux
vidéothèque là et j'ai regardé en me
levant je regardais [ __ ] charland
sauvage en cherchant remonte à l'an
dernier où j'ai vu état
aidé par m moi je connais deux trois
petits trucs pas grand chose mais je
collecte de trois petits trucs je sais
que tout ce que j'ai appris à l'école
c'est que du baratin
c'est clair la meilleure de toutes ces
jeunes d'arc
jeanne d'arc elle était illettré donc
elle ne pouvait pas parler un français
de la haute thur sujet d'hier puisque
c'était une paysanne ou encore pire que
as donc maintenant du jour au lendemain
elle se retrouve à parler anglais
imagine-toi pas les onglets alors
qu'elle n'avait pas parlé français
désigne déjà un problème tant que j'ai
dit à la vente et achat à monter à
cheval en plus et de plus on était dans
les années où une greluche je n'avais
pas vraiment grand chose à dire
on ce temps là il y avait vraiment rien
à dire mais c'est toi je te culbute
c'est tout bête toi je t'ai culbute
voilà et du jour au lendemain il a une
armée ouais c'est vrai il a une vision
de l'histoire de france qui
gagne et je te raconte mme malone là
quand j'ai fait un casting n'a point
fort je n'avais pas débuté dans le
métier j'ai fait un casting je suis allé
un casting de publicité
donc j'arrive l'âge
de la casting se taisent parce le story
board jeudi story board elle arrive
après elle m'explique un petit voilà
c'est une publicité pour gérard pasquier
tu vas tu m'as dit voilà c'est un
aventurier donc qui qu'avec cette femme
genre un peu indiana jones --une une
femme james bond girl vachement bien
habillé en pasquier et toute la ville
compte à l'aventuré qu'ils coupent qui
découpent la machette ce qu'avance
demandait d'un bandage ined indigènes
qui arrive qui les emmène au village la
chef des chefs des chefs du village qui
arrivent et qui baragouine quelque chose
la
viande et voilà ça c'est henri
brevets écoute moi c'est pas ça le truc
c'est le truc c'est jallet cela je dis
mais c'est vachement bien habitants
on est un blague pour faire leur pour
faire le l'aventurier avec la bonne
femme c'est super vous innovez c'est
super non non c'est pour l'indigène
j'étais vert m'envoyer dans les âges les
oiseaux le ciel est amer en 80 chez pas
combien c'est taghmaoui mon poto 500
voiliers là bas il m'a envoyé là bas je
vais là-bas et comme j'étais moi même
j'avais dix kilos en plus donc j'arrive
en marcel et ce en plein été julien
échauffement table je fais là-bas
j'arrive et on me dit est ce que vous
pouvez parler comme un gosse de city
plusieurs
avaient consenti moi j'habite pas dans
une cité mois après midi non mais voilà
tu vois tu voyages à rabais je dirais
g27 pich
27 pays je me vois pas moi faire le bus
de 17 piges après je suis même dit bon
on va vous trouver un autre ou là où il
ya des hommes et je regardais me dit
vous faites quoi comme sport tas il est
brave et elle commence à regarder si je
fais du ping pong je fais du tennis de
table m 10 alors on a un rôle pour vous
vous mettez là et vous bougez pas à le
poteau le pralin le poteau ton problème
à toi en plus de brême de daniel c'est
que tout le monde te crois que tu me
manqueras steve hill et carthage suite
carteron martiniquais et mais il
m'arrive souvent d'avoir des victimes
parlent en arabe je peux pas leur
répondre mais prennent pour un mec qui
veut par l'entente la plus facile
sa soeur alice marconnet souvent toi tu
vois commissaire à toi moi j'ai des fois
je vois commissariat et donc à temps
mais bien sûr ça arrive ils étaient
visés alors qu'ils ne sont pas les
oreilles et serrières et 4 heures tu
sors a laissé beaucoup
d'habitants manas comme il sait rien et
huawei moi j'adore ça on m'appelle
mamadou mamadou j'ai dit arrête
m'appelle charles
paccou j'ai dit tu continues à pour le
moment douze étapes les martinez sanchez
convalescent maintenant même si jean
gabin
tabac drogue tu connais tout le monde là
ouais j'ai déjà vu vous n'êtes jamais
aisé de m6 jean gabin tu as déclaré
comme ce dos je pouvais pas prendre de
longs parce que c'est un facho un trou
de balle
alors que gabin ça te rappelle mais
l'audience où seuls tout ça en face et à
kamsar 1 et puis dans mélodie en
sous-sol l'ancien braqueur il s'appelle
charles comme toi donc voilà donc ça ça
aide les braquages sont a fait un
tract encore des bijoux à ma mère
parler de ça
il ya plusieurs formules il a fait 50
tonnes vie à berlin-ouest c'est mieux
que l'est est je pense tu as appris
l'allemand alors si genève schnell
comment c'était rumbach
mais
faut dire que déjà eu des débuts
difficiles dans la vie parce que à 10
ans tes parents divorcent mais ton père
le supporte pas et et ton père repasse
ta mère et son conjoint dans un parking
37 rue saint fargeau en 77 ouais
voilà
ta profond que l'ambiance en herbe rase
de tout à l'heure tu fais que ça et ton
père est parti en calèche comme tu dis
ouais et partir en calèche je crois il
était à melun comme les lacets l'entend
pas ainsi ouais pas me la s
mais le sud et toi tu es parti à la dass
wesh sportive noces alors quand tu pars
de l'ada study les abus sexuels ça
existe
sébastien prendre peur ajoute non il
faut avoir une fourchette d'un moment il
a mis cette approche est un je pense que
avec une fourchette on peut faire un tas
de choses bt piqué
heureusement tu as découvert le hip hop
ouais la branche dure du hip hop quand
même un la la branche non je me suis
posé dessus c'est tout enfin les requins
vicié c'est pas des temps quand même nom
n'était de joyeux petit compagnon peux
t'imaginer déjouer petit compagnon qui
20 points commencé à voir tous des
problèmes à la bicoque way partir de là
le hip hop il arrivé on avait tous un
point commun aussi c'était la danse
voilà alors tu es déjà venu ici c'était
pourtant premier album un qui s'appelle
ma vie et le morceau c'est je t'emmerde
je t'emmerde j'temmerde et je t'emmerde
joue les quais tous les week-ends tous
les comptes dresse concrets tirés c'est
là qu'hier joue les braves tous les
lycéens métaux mais la vérité sur toi
t'as pas mis de l'argent sur
l'euthanasie la famille des branches de
france gall
respire aussi
alors aujourd'hui tu es à la fiche de
banlieue 13 produit par luc besson
magnéto serge bien
paris 2013 dont les cités ghettos
entourée d'un mur d'isolement
les gangs règne en maître absolu
quel est le but de prendre me sens quand
on sait qu'on n'a aucune chance de la
réussir vous voulez je désamorcer une
bombe venue de la pire des banlieues
dans laquelle j'ai jamais mis les pieds
avouez que c'est pas très actif d'albums
trois heures pour monter cette merde ce
qui concerne les lieux on vous a trouvé
un guide les taux transfert
parce qu'en plus il faut travailler en
tandem tu rencontreras c'était
quand tu sors ton annuel de police
certains en garde à la page suis dans la
merde mais dallas retrouver cette bombe
plutôt qu'une que ta gueule comme tous
les bourgeois qui critique qu'est ce que
tu veux plus
te préviens si tu me touches je veux
bien m'occuper d'elle il est passeur et
l'ama bon ben ça fait de raison de
rester présent
c'est quoi ce truc là j'ai pas un cadeau
tu as ces cinq adolescents mon frère
y
a un truc était urgent ton histoire ça
sent l'embrouillé
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont plus à perdre chez
oh lord
ces babioles qui est en train de
défoncer la j'ai piqué secoueront de
merck avait plus de fraîcheur une
réfugiée
pas mal aiguillé mon gars ici c'est pas
monaco c'est bagdad
par
jean gabin et notre invité ce soir à
c'est un vrai film d'action tadis
afrique vraiment à sa suite ça ressemble
un peu à une comédie romantique
surmonter ce coup de foudre tu dis
aujourd'hui le cinéma français est
rempli de fils de et de filles 2 qui
prennent toute la place ouais c'est des
fois c'est un peu emmerdant parce que tu
dis ouais tu peux être la fille ou le
fils ou le cousin intel ça veut pas dire
qu'ils savaient pas dire tu sais faire
de la comédie qu'ils soient acteurs ou
chanteurs ou c'est pas parce que ton
père et c'est un footeux qui tisse aussi
sera aussi au foot et c'est justement au
devant de la scène et moi passions que
des débats fils de qui sont pas bons non
plus ouais c'est clair mais des neveux
s'achemine souvent
des fils adoptif
ça va pour toi la ville en ce moment
dans non je m'éclate 1 c'est bien la
quarantaine joyeuse non
maintenant est ce que tu es prêt pour
une interview bisounours râlons
interview bisous
vous aviez quel âge pour votre premier
bisou
fait part aux trois quarts est un c'est
quand la dernière fois que vous avez
pleuré
à semaine dernière pourquoi au parloir
non je me suis coincé dans une lourde
suppose un doigt dans une bourde way est
une contrepétrie c'est pas un chagrin
d'amour ou non non non et votre couleur
préférée c'est quoi c'est le noir est
votre fleur préférée
à pâquerettes problème
si jean gabin vous avez attendu
longtemps avant d'offrir votre virginité
à une jeune fille
douze ans
c'est quoi la soirée idéale à 2 pour
vous
elle et moi c'est tout cent personnes
dont un à suffire
vous préférez quand harry rencontre
sally ou une nuits blanches à seattle et
nuits blanches à seattle et amélie
poulain vous avez aimé je peux regarder
vous avez pleuré à la fin du grand bleu
on parle que non plus
quelle est la chose la plus romantique
que vous ayez faite dans votre vie à
promettre un silencieux
offrir des fleurs et des pâquerettes
idiote j'te dis
c'est quand la dernière fois qu'une
femme vous a blessé enfin au sens figuré
bien sûr
il ya six mois
il ya six mois voilà on a fait quoi à
passer grand chose mais là c'est ouais
t'as ta blessés samedi n'a pas changé
l'eau des peintres a été pour lui
c'est un détail pour vous
ce soir et des dons
ce soir il fait france gall soirée thema
d'hier soir et
bien il asséna blaquart s'asseoir que
nous allions
vous l'appellerait comment votre premier
enfant
théo
c'est dans les bras de qui que vous vous
sentez le mieux tant mieux
c'est quoi votre définition de l'amour
puis je la cherche encore
et votre peluche favorite c'est là
qu'est née des requins
[Rires]
de cire poupée de son
j'ai rejoint aussi c'est sa chambre
c'est un homme s'intitule a laissé un
nounours mèche de cheveux ainsi un petit
nous nous un petit bizounours troubat
bol populaire
et dans dans le merveilleux monde de
disney sait quel personnage vous
préférez
jouer du piano debout
ah
ça balance pas mal à paris
qui n'avez vous jamais osé dire je
t'aime à
ma fille
on s'envoie un petit bisou la loi
j'en garde un roman soir
[Applaudissements]
jean gabin mesdames messieurs le
croisement parfait entre fifty cent et
michel audiard alors on s'est connu à
longtemps avec sa ge dans mes jetons et
je t'emmerde
public
ce ton très direct c'est là qu'hier
genoux les bras tous les lycéens
thomert vérité sur moi moi je peux et on
se retrouve ce soir avec votre deuxième
livre à l'est publié aux éditions don
quichotte
alors on y viendra mais prenons les
choses au commencement votre vrai nom
c'est charles m booth
charles parce que votre père était un
admirateur du général de gaulle et
d'ailleurs et vous voyez comme officier
j'ai raté mon coup vous avez vu valérie
j'ai pris un vrai gaulliste quand même
le pseudo donc c'est jean gabaret gens
que vous aimez georgen ah ouais j'aimais
bien
ce le phrasé de l'aigu ça va avant
c'est-à-dire star avoue ce langage d'un
poste qui avait à malakoff dans pas
d'amour et cetera et cetera maintenant
que c'est perdu un peu mais après c'est
bon il faut que ça tourne un peu mais
c'est surtout j'ai poussé avec tous les
tous les films des années 40 ans mais le
sous sol le mec qui s'appelle charles
est tout à fait c'est une des raisons
pourquoi j'ai tapé le blaze un
char l'ancien braqueur a envie de
remonter un dernier coup bah voilà ce
que j'ai fait en tendant le légal
au domaine bonjour
m
ah bon
le banc
alors vous c'est pas t'as de beaux yeux
tu sais c'est un beau cul tu sais mais
mais l'esprit est le même en question
surnom il ya petit chat ça c'est bien il
ya le fossoyeur là sur meetic le
fossoyeur c'est un peu emmerdant quand
même comme run alors sahan ambush vous
êtes d'origine camerounaise
vous êtes né en 1967 père comptable mère
dactylo et vous allez avoir dix ans
quand votre mère quitte votre père qui
ne le supporte pas et qui repasse votre
mère avec son nouveau mec dans un
parking 3 que mon père il attendait mon
géniteur attendait mamad aaron et son
conjoint dans le parking et il va
trouver la bonne idée d'aller à lui mais
le point le bus en premier comme ça et
vous éviter d'avoir les problèmes et
avec un frein il est après la ville a
collé six douilles ahmad harun dont une
dernière minute pour faire comme si
c'est un lapin
voilà c'est des trucs voilà c'est c'est
pour ça que j'appelle le géniteur est
très étonnant c'est que votre père donc
il part en calèche mais uniquement pour
cinq ans ouais ils ont mis crime
passionnel même hamadan est en cloque
donc ça fait pour moi ça en fait trois
mois j'en ai fait vite pour braquo d'une
a fait 5 pour rennes visionnarts du
globe c'est dingue alors vous dites la
mort de ma mère est ma plus grande
blessure ouais je crois que c'est la
chose que je ne pleure pas que je
n'arrive toujours pas à comprendre et c
c'est la raison de temps en temps je
saute un peu en l'air quand les guides
sont toujours en train de shalit à une
baronne tartare ou emma darwin c'est une
colle monde avance et si je dis docteur
m'a pas du tout tu vas comprendre que
nos regrets ou partez à la dass c'est
dexter un mode de vie et à la ds vous
dites là bas ton meilleur ami
c'est à fourche à la fourchette parce
qu'il faut se défendre contre les mecs
qui veulent vous baisez g le problème
c'est que vous arrivez avec des gus qui
l'ont déjà 18 ans donc temps en temps
avoir un petit derche pour des gus qui
ne voyaient pas être qu'on cesse bon bah
on appelle ça soit un viol soit une
tournante parce que vous voulez donc
vaut mieux avoir une fourchette et vous
faire comprendre la personne que je te
piquerait l'oeil le des ressources qu'il
faut avec derrière mais je te le pitre
est quand même il vaut mieux avoir
appris à ramasser les savonnettes avec
les pieds tout à fait mais je ne prends
pas de savon je préfère le shampoing
or à 17 ans vous vous retrouvez dans
paris hélas pour becqueter sur la
dépouille quoi ben faut survivre jadis
ben j'ai fait ce que je devais faire de
la rapine du jour et c'est aussi bien
l'état pendant quand j'avais des rôles
et voilà alors on fait des séjours en
calèche et ce qu'il faut dire à tous les
jeunes qui nous regardent c'est si vous
voulez faire des braquages la meilleure
formation ça reste la prison comme un
atout mais ça reste l'atout le voile a
jugé targus appelé josé j'ai oublié son
nom de famille et il avait 38 berges et
moi j'en avais 18 et j'ai tout appris a
braqué en théorie grâce à josé merci
réussissent et la première chose que
j'ai fait quand suis sorti j'ai braqué
voilà vous commencé à circuler avec la
bande des requins vicieux
c'est là commence d'ailleurs le livre
qui vous amène ce soir qui s'appelle à
l'est ça raconte en fait trois mois en
1988 ou vous donner avec les requins
vicieux ensuite vous partez en allemagne
de l'est à istanbul à chicago toujours
en quête d'oseille coin en quête de
zayed aventure c'est surtout natchaba de
mon propre patelin vous essayer de
découvrir si la verdure à l'époque
justement plus verte ailleurs même si
aperçu qu'ils étaient un peu plus guère
de temps en temps elle faisait en
allemagne il y en a qui partent sous les
cocotiers club lundi partout en
allemagne vous tombez pour braquage vous
fait sept ans de taule en allemagne
ouais au départ j'ai pris 33 33 puis
j'avais pas capté est difficile de
comprendre la demande 1 heureusement
qu'on appelle sa capitale capital fabre
à chaud c'est-à-dire l'argent mais voilà
je vais faire en sorte de sortir mais si
je fais le con tu savais dix ans à la
dass et 7 ans en prison c'est vraiment
parce que beaucoup de rappeurs ont fait
de la prison mais c'est bizarre s'est
jamais à cause de leurs disques
1 alors dans votre livre raconte des
histoire absolument rocambolesque
extraordinaire à un moment vous devez
livrer dix voitures de luxe à istanbul
voilà vous partez de berlin on traverse
l'autriche la yougoslavie de tito la
bulgarie la bulgarie la yougoslavie en
ce temps là la religion c'est la
raquette voilà je crois qu'il y avait
fallait laisser quelque chose et combien
vous avez de caisse en arrivant à
istanbul il y avait huit caisses alors
ensuite j'avais à chicago là vous menez
vraiment la vie des gangs de chicago et
c'est c'est quelque chose d'inimaginable
de raconter des trucs de fou à un moment
vous utilisez des gonzesses comme appât
way pour qu'il n'appelle les mecs si tu
as trop d'ozone était en train de lui
qui est trop beau ben non on n'est pas
le crif me dira de péter ouais
quand vous rentrez en france finalement
vous voulez écrire des livres en fait
déjà à l'époque et c'est doc gynéco qui
vous qui vous branche dans la musique
ont fait la veille mais dans la zik j'ai
un regard à louis blanc dans un studio
et quand j'arrive au rambour je vois
quatre et nos rages et fred chichin et
c'est pas ce n'est pas mon idée première
minute première c'est sûrement pas
écrire ou où commençait à gazouiller au
micro je voulais les mettre dans un
coffre est demandé 500 bars
voilà et il m'a dissuadé pour 27 milles
avec un chèque et puis je me suis retenu
et puis j'ai commencé
je t'emmerde j'temmerde
[Musique]
c'est en tous les cas on est ravi que
j'écrive y est pascal est super bien se
vérifier les histoires brief avec un
style la justice c'est ça qui est bien
alors vous pratiquez le strip work out
alors si des exercices en fait de force
avec des éléments du mobilier urbain
c'est du poids de corps c'est pas de la
musculation et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de faire d'eux de construire
un accord avec
seulement avec son corps vous faites
partie d'une équipe qui s'appelle apple
michelin new team
j'ai montré la photo à michel cymes to
time c'est que de la gonflette tracé
faut jamais vous gérez abonnés je suis
au contraire admiratif écoutez on va
voir ce que tu sais faire charles vas-y
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est pas le cirque pinder mais
bon voilà il ya pour les abdominaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la seconde longueur ce sera amusant
familiale
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
il a quel âge là je vais sur mes 49 bah
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu